Herzlichen Dank für
die vielen Kommentare
zum Film
"Schluss mit der Perioden-Scham".
Am Ende des Films fragte ich,
ob man Mensblut zeigen darf.
Ihr habt geantwortet, es gab positive
Kommentare, aber auch negative.
Auf einige will ich jetzt eingehen.
Z.B. hat Vaalleentina geschrieben:
Valentina,
das kann ich gut nachvollziehen.
Denn wir Frauen sehen ja
Monat für Monat unser rotes Mensblut.
Wenn man das rote Mensblut dann
auf Smartphones oder anderen
Bildschirmen sieht, denkt man:
"Huch, darf man das zeigen?"
"Ist das nicht verboten,
sollte man das nicht verstecken?"
Man erschrickt selbst,
dass man so denkt,
weil man ja weiss,
dass es etwas Natürliches ist.
Ich glaube, genau das ist es, was
in unserer Gesellschaft schiefläuft.
Ums Blut geht es auch
in den nächsten Kommentaren,
z.B. in jenem von Elisabeth Kharis.
Und auch Lukas D. Schmid schrieb,
es sei ein spannender Beitrag.
"Doch das erzwungene Zeigen des Blu-
tes finde ich persönlich überflüssig
und auch kontraproduktiv."
"Was will man damit erreichen?
Aufmerksamkeit?"
Ja, ehrlich gesagt schon. Ich wollte,
dass über das Thema gesprochen wird.
Ich wollte, dass man öffentlich
über die Menstruation diskutiert.
Und ich bin der Meinung, dass man es
eben nicht verstecken soll.
Ich wollte es sichtbar machen.
Deshalb habe ich
das Mensblut gezeigt, wie es ist.
Du, Fabienne V., hast geschrieben:
Du sagst es komplett richtig,
Fabienne:
Diese Frau musste ihre Gebärmutter
wegen Endometriose entfernen lassen.
Dadurch hat sie
keine Mensblutungen mehr,
aber die Eierstöcke und
der weibliche Zyklus sind noch da.
Dadurch hat sie gewisse Beschwerden,
z.B. dass sie sich down fühlt
oder Rückenschmerzen hat.
Darüber hat sie im Film gesprochen
und berichtet.
Lamm Fromm schrieb:
Da bin ich ganz anderer Meinung.
Für mich sind es keine
Pseudoprobleme, sondern Probleme,
die Hunderttausende Frauen haben.
Es sind relevante Probleme, die wir
wirklich ernst nehmen sollten -
in der Gesellschaft,
am Arbeitsplatz, in der Schule,
im Sportverein und in der Familie.
Ich finde,
man sollte diesen Frauen Raum geben,
damit die Betroffenen
offen darüber sprechen können
und sich nicht aus Scham
oder wegen schlechter Gefühle
verstecken müssen.
Richard Meier schreibt:
Ich glaube, genau das ist die Krux:
Die Werbung suggeriert uns,
dass es sich beim Mensblut
um eine blaue Flüssigkeit handelt.
Der erste Hersteller
von Damenhygieneartikeln
zeigte erst vor ca. fünf Jahren
eine rote Flüssigkeit,
die das Mensblut symbolisiert.
Es gab einen riesigen Aufschrei.
Das zeigt, dass das Thema noch immer
mit einem Tabu behaftet ist.
Noel Huber schrieb:
Ja, ich kann verstehen,
wenn man nicht gerne Blut sieht.
Aber bei Operationen oder Schwanger-
schaften wird ja auch Blut gezeigt.
In Filmen sieht man Blut
bei Verletzungen oder Unfällen.
Ich sehe nicht ein,
weshalb man ausgerechnet das Mensblut
verpixeln müsste.
Hier noch ein Kommentar von R D.
"Dieser Beitrag gibt aber meines Er-
achtens einen einseitigen Eindruck."
"Nicht alle Frauen
werden einmal pro Monat depressiv
und leiden wahnsinnige Schmerzen,
wie man
nach diesem Beitrag denken könnte."
Ja, R D, du hast natürlich recht.
Längst nicht alle Frauen
leiden unter starken Mensschmerzen.
Es ist übrigens
ziemlich ausgewogen im Film.
Und doch wollte ich zeigen,
dass der weibliche Zyklus
einen starken Einfluss
auf uns Frauen hat.
DaddyToxic schrieb etwas,
das ich sehr wichtig finde:
Es geht nämlich um Aufklärung.
"Ich denke,
daran müsste man etwas ändern,
sofern das noch nicht passiert ist."
Während meiner Recherchen
habe ich gesehen,
dass sehr viel läuft.
Man greift das Thema
in der Schule auf -
schon recht früh, und zwar nicht nur
mit den jungen Frauen bzw. Mädchen,
sondern auch mit den Jungs
bzw. jungen Männern.
Ich glaube,
das ist die richtige Richtung,
damit das Thema
endlich enttabuisiert wird.
Danke auch, dass du einen Kommentar
geschrieben hast, Shane O'Neill.
Ja -
darauf kann ich dir gerne antworten.
Natürlich hat es einen Einfluss
auf die Leistung der Frauen.
In gewissen Monaten stärker
und wirklich heftig.
Deshalb finde ich es ganz wichtig,
dass man darüber
sprechen darf und kann.
Damit genau jene Frauen,
die sich an gewissen Tagen im Monat
nicht wohl fühlen bzw. Schmerzen
haben, es nicht verstecken müssen.
Dass sie nicht auf die Zähne beissen,
keine Schmerzmittel nehmen müssen,
sondern dass man in der Gesellschaft
oder am Arbeitsplatz
Verständnis dafür zeigt.
Zum Schluss Frau Muster,
die schreibt:
Das finde ich auch.
Es brauchte
von diesen Frauen viel Mut,
sich so zu zeigen
und offen darüber zu sprechen.
Ich hoffe, dass dies anregt,
dass viele darüber sprechen -
ob Frauen oder Männer -, sodass
endlich eine Diskussion stattfindet.
Wenn ihr nichts verpassen und weiter-
hin auf dem Laufenden bleiben wollt,
abonniert doch unseren Kanal.
Wenn ihr jetzt noch Fragen habt
oder euch etwas in den Sinn kommt,
hinterlasst weiterhin Kommentare -
darüber freuen wir uns sehr.